you just need to understand the game and
once you understand the game but this
doesn't sound like
you we're talking about other people
this doesn't sound like you you do sound
like you're having a horrible time
the streets aren't for you it's not yet
anywhere yeah not right now the shoes
actually aren't for you
hey yo jeez it's uh bright and sunny
monday
because we're feeling good feeling great
how are you
yeah wait swimming on that was live um
feeling great feeling feeling good
feeling great how are you yeah that's
outcast i'm sure
i don't know about that feeling great
feeling good how are you
uh right guys so you know the drill
patriots patreon pops
and i will tell you why we've got
well here's the here's the gist guys
right
at the minute you've got like over a
year's worth of content just
brewing in there marinated marinating in
there
and you're thinking that's cool but i
want a little bit more
a little bit more bang for my buck
yeah all right i see your bang
i see your buck um
we do conversations with our patrons on
stereo
if you're willing to bump up to that
tier three you get conversations with us
on stereo live live in the ting
so jump in that enjoy that hold that
communicate that rags tell a friend to
tell a friend to tell their mom
because she wants to chat to us too yeah
everyone's trying to chat everyone's
trying to chin work man
um so guys the link's in the description
jump on the patreon and enjoy
on top of that um you already know who
brought you today's episode
you know who's sponsoring the episode
today the one the only
landscape dog so what my skate will they
do they've got this thing called the
perfect package right and the perfect
package
comes with all the tools you need to
literally have the perfect package
if you're slacking down there the little
snips dip the blends the fades
you can use all sorts it's an extra
three inches
it's an extra three inches at least
perfect package
bang just flop edible
these these look at it it's edible
jokes so along with that when you get
your perfect package guys it comes with
two free gifts as well
and that's a pair of boxers these boxes
are
smooth colors chaffins slide on boxes
bro there's figure skater things
you feel like you're gliding bro roll
the disco
um and along with that they come with a
wash bag
um the wash brush he did a secret
we found it and it literally you know
like pulp fiction at the end where they
open the box and just go oh yeah just
gone
i thought the thing was done i was like
oh that's cool and then i just as i
would get rid of the box you you open up
the box
at the bottom and there's just this
leather
just rich clean toiletry bag
bro it's essential bro perfect it's
essential i put all my things in there
immediately
dash my old scabby thing away but dash
my skating where i had toothpaste stains
on it everything bro
dashed it away yeah man yeah all about
the mask toilet bike what about the
man's skates
rich um so guys if you want to jump on
make sure you head over to mansgate.com
and use the code
sng that's 20 off and free shipping
manscape.com code sng show your boy some
love and uh
yeah man line our pockets nice that's
all we ask we don't ask for much you
know
yeah we really don't really don't um but
yeah let's get back to the show here we
go
so this fun fact resonates with me like
almost every day
male koalas are one of the laziest
animals on the planet
that makes sense and spend up to 22
hours a day sleeping
even when it comes to mating they don't
leave their home instead of them between
12
and 3 in the morning they'll bellow out
amazing call and make the female come to
them
just when they want to know look at the
picture of my man sleeping i slump
he is slumped bro yeah that makes sense
they are they encapsulate how i feel
sometimes
i just want to sleep and chill and if i
want to bang
come through i ain't going to see your
family i can't be asked for an away game
i can't be asked for an away game just
come through yeah yeah chill at mine
my dunya is nice my bed is comfy and we
can have fun
yeah and then you can yeah then you can
bounce
yeah i mean the mating call is done you
can bounce
to be fair you are the male koala rose
you are a male caller i just want to
do nothing i know what you mean bro i
know what you mean i want to
chill but here's what it is we've got to
move we've got to make money and we've
got to be active
that's life i hear you man i was oh
i was relaxed last night that chill
finished some editing i laid my head
back like this
and i just breathed actually breathe
does
24 hour stint that's what i want yeah
um but that's interesting bro you know
how i know koalas are lazy
is that you know when they had all those
really bad forest fires in australia
these men were just dying onto the trees
they didn't move
they didn't give a [ __ ] they didn't
bother moving they're just like nah
it's gonna get me anyway therefore it's
gonna get me anyway
blessed what's the point bless their
cotton socks oh
literally just asked they just found ash
attached to this tree bro that's all
peek man that is pete i think that was
the first
that was the first thing to my knowledge
that happened in 2020 i think that
happened like
december 2019 january 2020 the
australian fires
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was the first thing that
happened it's true
it's true so many things happened last
year man it's true
wow that's crazy i can actually now that
you've said it resonates with you
i literally just imagined you being fast
asleep
say it's like four in the morning and
then like your apartment building just
starts burning
and i sprint in there kick the door down
like frags it's burning get a [ __ ] up
and if it's already in the room yeah i
can see you being like
i just come back to sleep it's too late
for me bro just go
just go i'd be so knackered just go
let the thing take me forever i've done
enough in this world
bro let it swallow me hard
it's true it's actually true um
but yeah man that's a good fun fact i
like animal ones for some reason i think
i might start doing don't hold me to
this guys but i might start doing
a random maybe like twice a month
a random fun fact about animals and not
necessarily just the fun facts but like
a
a random species kind of thing because
there's so many i found one
yesterday or the day before about an
animal i've never even heard of in my
entire life
you know i just want to start doing like
random animals on it because i love
animals for some animals animal facts
are interesting they're so interesting
they actually are interesting so
interesting
i've never heard of or seen before so i
might start educating you man
yeah bro when you do the animal facts
they're probably my favorite
i love them same they're so interesting
because it's one of those ones where
certain facts i feel like a lot of
people may already know of if they're
like about humans or about this or about
that but animal facts not that many
people know certain
things about animals and it's just like
it's very educational even though it's
nonsense yeah it's still a random fun
fact nature is crazy nature is crazy and
i feel like that's the essence of this
segment yeah bro i know fun fact is
something that makes you think so yeah
i might start doing a random animal
facts like
every other week or so okay so we'll see
how that goes
right i've got a question for you okay
like what is this like a tricky one
what rating would you give yourself do
you okay cool
so first of all this is something i kind
of stole from like another show i was
listening to and i thought oh that's so
funny
but like what rating would you give
yourself out of 10
pennies-wise as i feel today or in
general
just day-to-day life and the best you've
ever felt the best i've ever felt like
in terms of trim gym all of that blah
blah i'd probably say
i'd give myself like a humble 7.5 humble
7.5
that's good like on a don't look at me
up and down like that
unlike my the best i've ever felt like a
fresh best man can get
yeah yeah i wouldn't say i won't go past
7.5 i don't think
that's humble enough cool why i'm just
wondering would you say that
like so if you're like a let's call
yourself a manchester 7.5
okay are you like a would that make you
like a lagos 10
um i wouldn't
or would you okay let's before we
stretch the legos yeah if you're a
manchester
7.5 yeah do you think you hold that in
london
no would you say like a london six i
probably say i'm like a london six
because there's
because i the way i know that is because
there's women in manchester
but there's women in london you know
there's brazilians in london
there's different colombians there's
different species in london it makes no
sense
it's like what you said in the previous
episode like the colonial melting pot
it's just different in london it's not
the same up here yeah there are
paintings up here and they could be a
seven there could be an eight out here
up here but perfect example when
me you um jay and rem went to see drake
in london
in the o2 yes the amount of paintings
that were there bro
you can't see that many paintings up in
manny you can see
some paintings in money but the amount
of paintings that were there
in one in conclusion it didn't make
they were sense different um types and
sizes and skin tones it was like
nah london girls yeah yeah different
to manny girl so i would say i'm a young
on a good day like a six in
like a london six like a london six okay
but obviously girls aside do you that
that's
for you to be in london six even if
there was pain girls or butters girls
it's only based on the other mandom so
you're saying this
man in london um for you to
knock down to a six there must be a man
i would like to assume so purely
and also i feel like a lot more people
in london
are i feel like it's everywhere but not
necessarily superficial but in terms of
they look at certain characters like
hype for example
and like what you have what you wear
what you dress yeah
drive yeah yeah yeah so that in turn
bumps up other people's numbers or bumps
down other people's numbers you know
yeah yeah and i feel like they're not
looking at what i look like or what he
looks like
they're looking at you everything like
um bella for example when she said she
thought
um what's his name gibby on
his buff and i'm thinking i don't think
he's a buff guy i think he's
he's a handsome looking dude but you
only like him because his voice is great
yeah and they get clouded by the voice
women get closer
by features extra stuff what does he
look like give me a mug shot because
that's what we're talking about here
he's getting profit
i don't care about his voice i don't
care what he does for a living yeah is
he paying
yeah yeah yeah yeah women don't
understand that question they don't
understand that question at all they
actually don't understand that question
they don't when you said um your brother
message the girl or girl message her
brother is he peng
he's six three yeah like things that
aren't you're not answering my question
big man you know yeah women actually
don't understand
what that means they don't they see a
guy
elsie has and they add that to his race
oh yeah it has to come into it they
always add that
and they're like yeah i know but he's
like he's got money in that and you're
like yeah but i didn't ask that
we can add that on later because i'm
i'm not afraid or ashamed to say that if
i see an average looking girl who's got
banging body i'd be like her body's
banging i wouldn't necessarily say she's
paying i'll be like
her body's banging my face oh yeah so
yeah you're allowed to say his car is
nice
exactly you're allowed to say these
things but if i'm asking you directly do
you think he's paying or do you think
he's this
and you say yes because he's got this
he's got this he's six three yeah yeah
there's another thing as well like
yesterday when same thing with bella
again
when he was watching the football and
then she was like oh my man's bar for my
man's bar for
he's buffing this and then you're like
oh but like he's brazilian so it's just
a brazilian in him
and you're like yeah i do love a
brazilian to be fair you're like yeah
but that's not what we're talking about
who's better looking for him it's not
hard it's not hard
this is it they they cloud everything
into it yeah that's true
i would say based on how i dress um like
either i wear shorts as long as sun's
out wearing shorts yeah i know what you
mean that's not that's not peng
so i would say i'm like a london four
oh based on that because they because i
know they take my the dress sense into
equations
london takes fashion too seriously
seriously it's certainly money to be
fair
london is a bigger scale but i think
guys get away with it more in money
okay i think guys like a comfort yeah i
think like
yeah women don't get to get away with it
as much in money
it makes sense it's very like
pretentious but guys can
can get away with it in money yeah
they've got like a brand on
yeah they can kind of get away with it
in london you just can't that can't run
you can't just rock up here in westfield
wearing what you want
wearing your own merch and some cargo
shorts
get out of here you're four yeah
i think yeah i think i'm like a manny
six okay a london four
i'm like a northampton eight
let's [ __ ] all in north bro i'm a
grimsby 11.
i don't even know where grimsby is i've
heard of grimsby i couldn't tell you
where it is yeah i don't know where it
is
i'd say you're like a um a groom where
would you be
that's hilarious you'd be in 11 in like
um where would they love a bit of you
i feel like you'll be like a derby 11.
um yeah i've been to derby once or twice
but it was obviously decades ago before
yeah you're like a derby 11. um
i don't think there's that i can't see
there being that much mixed race
competition in there for you either
in derby yeah i think you'll be quite
sore after a derby i'm not really
sort of through in like then wales ends
them scotland
as well that means where there's not
that many black people yeah you'd do
well in like edinburgh
yeah you'll be like a glasgow 10.
guys going cardiff 10. you'd clean up
there
that's hilarious i think there's a few
there's a few scottish mixes though as
well so i don't know how well i'm doing
in glasgow there's quite a few mixes in
up north there
yeah yeah yeah so i think i'm more of
like a yeah i'm like a grinsby 11
um maybe like a
maybe like a devon 10.
down south yeah these farmer man yeah i
might do well there
exeter line yeah
my name oh my days that's jokes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think they'll do
well there
you're like a you're all but you're also
like a
i'd say you're like a paris
7.5 as well probably yeah same as money
yeah oh that
yeah you'd do well in paris but you
wouldn't do amazing i know
yeah females in paris paris things
are bad again i feel like
maybe again i don't know this could this
is probably just based on what i see on
socials
i also feel like because paris is paris
like you know i feel like it's somewhat
superficial as well
i would like definitely where in the
brand definitely
um from what i've seen though sorry to
get you off from what i've seen when
i've been there
is that that i feel like there's two how
do i explain it
similar to money paris is similar to
money in that like
i know what you wouldn't say what would
you think i'm gonna in terms of
paris once you step outside of paris
there's not much or no no
okay you're way off bro okay cool cool
cool cool cool i thought that's what
we're going to say
because money is like in the city center
this is like london kind of yeah yeah
yeah you step outside of this stuff
paris is like it is like that but like
paris is like because there's banging
people there
you can clean up you don't have to be
like obviously it's a superficial place
if you roll in superficial circles yeah
but you can also work at like a cafe
and just be banging and get and get
popped
but there's no there's not really much
of like a um like a hierarchy
that makes it like it's not like they're
not all just money hungry there they
understand that people are just banging
yeah
and they're just down to do things that
make sense yeah yeah yeah paris is
different like that
there's there's women in that bro
they love a dark-skinned guy in paris as
well there should do an african guy
they love an african guy in france they
love them yeah yeah yeah
there's so many mixed-race people in in
paris
i would i'm like a paris five because
i'm just there in the lineup i don't
stand out at all
in the lineup i'm just in the lineup oh
number five in the lineup yeah bro
it's the same yeah i wouldn't do well in
paris i wouldn't do well at all
and it's just like being in english that
means nothing but then again
i feel like i feel like the initial
because i'm dark skinned the initial
gas might be there obviously then they
find out i'm english
because i don't speak french yeah that
could all true
nikki'd either go for or against yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm not sure
who knows man i love the accent though
ah bro
french accent is it's my favorite
i know it is it's actually my favorite
it's like it's very sexy
yes it's live man i'm here for it i
don't know
anyone french but maybe one day
i know i know we go with this well she's
not i think she's algeria when they
speak french
i think you told me about this before
yeah yeah she's um her accent is very
sexy
very sexy every time she says my name is
like wolf
it's sexy it's very sexy yeah man i'm
here for that
um you said your fan request yeah yes
i don't think we've done a final case in
a minute but we haven't
all right this was this got sent to us
like late last year
so apologies um a big i've been a big
fan of the podcast ever since episode
one and i would like
i would like you to help me on a
situation so i'm at uni first year my ex
came to the same uni as me and obviously
we have been seeing each other and stuff
however
i've been seeing other girls too one
time i smashed two other girls on the
same day i smashed my ex
my three things so three things in total
i'm assuming
um however i never really enjoyed two of
the other two smashes
i was just kind of doing it for the sake
of doing it
does this mean i'm still not over my ex
and if so
i should should i get back with her
because when i'm smashing these other
girls
it's not the same you know like i'm
having to try even i'm even trying
hard to get up and when i'm there it's
just like no
but with my ex the sex is unreal she did
find out about me seeing other girls and
went ape [ __ ] so i don't know what do i
do
um and he sent another one i think the
month after
um i've been living the uni life and
stuff i do really like her it's just
that i want
i don't want to be tied down now when
i'm in my first year but i don't really
know one
i can't get my words up i've been living
i'm so tired i've been living the uni
life and stuff
i do really like her it's just i don't
want to get tied down right now i'm in
my first year of uni
but i do really like spending time with
her when it's not just sex
i don't know how to deal with the female
attention like as
soon as i see a girl who's hot it's like
i just want to bang everything else
being there bro
everything else doesn't matter but then
i put but then i have post nut syndrome
and it's like [ __ ] it
and i think about my ex even harder do i
go with her and just
this guy doesn't use punctuation what
none of them do bro
do i go with her and just unjust her
or do i play the field and forget any
advice would help
lads i'm 18 by the way so yeah well done
on the podcast you guys
are funny as [ __ ] you helped me through
lockdown you [ __ ] legends thank you
so much
cool so recap um fan since day one
he's got x he's at uni at the moment
he's um
playing the field his ex came to see him
at uni
on one day he banged two girls as well
as his ex
the two girls he banged he wasn't really
feeling that he even struggled to get up
because he was just like meh but when he
smashed his ex
the sex was unreal the basic question is
am i over
do i feel do does he feel like he's over
his ex or does he feel like he should
get back with his ex because
he's not really into [ __ ] yeah he
wants to play the field but he's clearly
it's clearly not working for him
doesn't want to play him but phil
doesn't want to play him
his mind wants to play the field like
his heart wants to play with his girl
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um what are your
thoughts
i don't know man i feel like he's
answered his own question he's basically
answering a question he's literally said
i want to play the field but when i'm
playing the field i'm not feeling it
so you've answered your own question man
said what should i do it's just like
well don't play the field there because
you don't like it i feel like you're
forcing yourself to play the field
because i feel like
when you go to uni everybody has that um
what's the word i'm looking for everyone
has that um
not necessarily feeling but that thought
process of our uni firstly especially
smashing have a girlfriend can't be in
relationships need to smash you need to
do this best time of your life and maybe
also because i'm assuming like the
people in your circle like your other
friends male friends for example
are playing the field as well say add a
bit of pressure on you yeah yeah to make
you not want to be with a girl bro we've
been there but there's loads of pressure
to be singled in you yeah of course
there's loads of pressures especially if
like if you're like
one of the lads like there's loads of
pressure to be single
and then it sounds cool it does i've
been there as well there's times where
i've been there when i'm like oh bro
yeah
i'm just out of bang and then literally
you get in the mix and i'm just like
what am i doing here man there was a
time when um
there was a time where there was this
girl that came through
and the whole setup was like it's one of
them things where the whole
setup was sounded so cool
[Music]
but in in like actuality
even whilst i'm living it yeah i was
like this is whack
but i'm still gonna make it sound cool
to the fellas of course
yeah yeah yeah because this is this is
this is the game we're playing
and i need to seem cool so it was a girl
that we met on a night out she was older
than us
she was the sister of another friend
that we kind of knew
but anyway she randomly messaged me one
night when i was just getting ready to
go to bed
she'd been out said she wanted to come
through i was like gang um
she rolled through did the team the
thing didn't really go very well
it was a bit awkward like it was i i
thought i found her attractive but then
when we got down to it
i don't actually think i do find you
that attractive and so there's all these
loads of
little different things and then just
like at the end of it i think we
we like did the biz for like five
minutes
and then kind of like phased out and i
made an excuse to like go downstairs
oh i need the toilet i'll be back up in
a sec and then like i went downstairs
and i kind of just like sat on the side
for a minute i was just like oh this is
brutal like i don't even want to go back
up there damn
yeah bro i know which one was this which
yard was it yeah
this was in nicole street
okay so i lost art okay um
and yeah bro it just like she came
through
and then luckily once i'd gone back up
there she'd fallen asleep
i was like gang and i hated the fact
that i was like sick
she's falling asleep that's decent now i
don't have to go through this anymore
and then like i kind of just like
slipped in bed next to her and just
she was stalkers in bed didn't damn see
that face should pull in that's not what
i was putting
i saw that she was still like naked and
i was just like
just rolled over and went to sleep then
she kind of just woke up and got [ __ ]
and left the next day
and i felt so dirty the next day and i
was just like i don't know i just felt
that was horrible
was it because it was her or was it
because i don't think it was just about
her i think it was a time in my life
where
again i'd been playing the field for a
little while
and there was probably girls along the
way that i liked more than others
of course there would be and then you
kind of just
force yourself to go through with it
because you're like is she is she paying
yes she's down
i'm playing the field i'm out here
living my whole life what
plausible excuse do i have to not go
through with this
and i thought which you convinced
yourself you're down especially if the
fellas are like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sick and
then you're just like oh
cause i know like i remember at the time
thinking oh if i put in the group chat
that some random girl she was like a
good few years older than us as well at
the time
she was like i don't think you you if i
explain it to you
who she was you'd might remember yeah
but anyway
like i remember thinking after putting
the group chat that this like 25
26 year old woman at the time we were
like 21.
um he's just messaging me saying she
wants to come through and smash like the
fellas are going to be guests
even though i wasn't guessing yeah but
the fact that i knew that you man would
be guessed
made me guess yeah do you know what i
mean of course of course of course and
then for the story yeah
all for the story it was just a painful
experience
just like ugh i literally felt gross
after and i was just like
bro what what am i actually doing here
like is this really what i want to do
and i remember if i was in his situation
so i'm assuming how i felt in that
moment is similar to how he felt
yeah and if he's uh after that i didn't
i wasn't thinking about anyone after
that i was just thinking this is yuck
but if
my man's out here thinking ugh i miss my
ex after that
no he needs to get out of the game he
needs to go the streets he needs to
hang up his boots bro you can come back
at a later date
if you need to the streets are always
going to be there streets ain't going
nowhere
when i was um when i was in uni or when
we were in uni rather
my first year i was single so i've kind
of like
seeing seeing what the potentials could
be i wasn't a dog in first year i was
just
doing my i can't remember how many
people i [ __ ] in my first year it
wasn't even that like
i don't say that in a sense that because
it was a lot you weren't dogging i just
wasn't dogging you weren't dogging at
all
at all and then in my second house i'm
dogging in my first year really either i
think you bloomed in like your second
year you bloomed in my second year
you cleaned up in second year in my
second and third year
um i had to go yes you know that i had a
girl so i wasn't even playing fields
like that but
god it was her it was said again i said
god i miss her
who your girl from then yeah why she was
just so lovely
she was she is what she is i think she
was i think i miss her because she was
like the first obviously you know when
you say stuff about like oh
um when we talk about now like oh if
your boy's got a girl
she's family yeah yeah that was my first
experience of that yeah yeah
with anyone because you were the only
probably because i knew her briefly
because before she was your girlfriend
because you were friends with her anyway
so i knew her before and then she was
your girlfriend so i knew it got to know
even better
and then she was just gang yeah and then
i remember like
just like i enjoyed waiting for the
shower with her do you know what i mean
like if someone was in the shower yeah
and she was waiting so she'd be like in
a towel waiting for the shower yeah with
her like
shower cap on and i'll be there with my
towel and i'm just i'm on and stuff
like i just enjoyed it yeah i just felt
like oh this is like my sister in the
house
like i never had a sister yeah and i
don't know i just enjoyed it at the time
and she made you giggle like a yap
that's cool
and she made you giggle like a little
kid and i was like my boy's in love
that's the thing with me like i love
being like the way i am with you if i
have that with a girl because it's
ten times great you know it's the best
feeling in the world knowing that you
can be yourself
with your girl yeah yeah at all
whichever or vice versa or be yourself
with a guy if you're a girl
yeah yeah yeah bisexual gauge you know
what i mean it's yeah best feeling in
the world
that's dope bro um but sorry getting
back to my man's point
all right so first year i was single but
i wasn't talking second year
on the contrary to you i was in a
relationship second and third year
but whilst you were cleaning up in
security i was jealous brother oh
the same way you said r you love the
fact that i was with her and
you could see us like being one person
blah blah blah making me giggle you guys
having a great conversation
i was just thinking this man's cleaning
up and i'm here tied the [ __ ]
down you know it was such a contrast of
opinions well i know exactly what
i mean that's got nothing that's not
taking away anything i had with this
girl
because my relationship with her at the
time was fantastic and
me and her still like we don't
necessarily talk as much but we
we still say happy birthday to each
other blah blah blah because it's one of
them was
never had any bad blood between us but
i think because he's in this situation
right now
people feel like uni's do or die like
uni you have to get it
bro i've got three years to bust as many
nuts
as possible and it's it's not the way
like because it's not like you don't die
at the end of uni
life doesn't stop oh bro you can hold it
up for years to come
but for years like i peaked when i came
to money yeah you did and that was
20 i was 26. you were cleaning up when
you got here when i came to money as
soon as you landed
it's just it was different it was
different when i came to my
first living in london well i was
supposed to my uni experience yeah yeah
yeah
so i feel like people rush not
necessarily rush but people
because they know of the expectations of
what happens or may happen in uni they
feel like okay i need to
hire myself now yeah yeah and then okay
i will grow up
yeah yeah yeah yeah and life doesn't
work that way life isn't a script you
just gotta play it as it is you gotta
roll your dice and just roll with a
punch yeah i think you also need to get
comfortable with the fact because it
sounds like he's
apprehensive about going back to his ex
because he feels like
if i go back to my ex i'm gonna be stuck
there yeah there's no way out now yeah
like like he said i just don't want to
be tied down so he's basically saying i
don't even want to play the field i want
to be on my ex
but i'm scared of her just tying me down
so
i think he needs to go in there with the
fact that like you can leave whenever
you want bro
you can do what you're what the [ __ ] you
can't go to he just visited the
university
i thought she went there no she went she
said came to see him in uni oh really
yeah i thought she
came to my uni let me double check but
continue let me double but um
regardless came to see me um
yeah yeah yeah you're right came to the
same uni all right cool okay yeah yeah
yeah
um so yeah but like yeah he's definitely
concerned that like if he goes with her
um like he's he's a lot he's in a
relationship like that
but even so like if you go i think you
will feel a lot better if you go over
there with the mentality of
bro like um
i can leave tomorrow if i don't like it
here i can go
if you go in there with that then you're
just gonna be a lot happier because the
yeah the streets are gonna be waiting
for you whenever you're ready
they are and these will always be there
just go with what you want when you want
it
yeah don't force it bro because yeah bro
there's if there's one thing i know
about the streets
you can't learn to love it oh god no you
either like it or you
you don't you don't you can't grow to
love the streets
you're going to hate it but you can
definitely grow to hate it
but you can i i agree with you you can't
grow to like it but you can grow to
understand the stream you can go to
understand the stream
understand yeah because there's
definitely occasions where you might
think you don't like it yeah but really
you just haven't understood it yeah you
just like
the field enough to understand don't
understand through yeah these men are
playing three steps ahead of you
damn you don't know what road you're
running google maps is locked you don't
know what's going on and you think i
hate the streets
you just haven't understood the game yet
that's like when i started playing
flipping monopoly
i thought i [ __ ] hate monopoly i just
didn't understand it i just didn't
understand the angles i didn't tell them
now your man's cleaning up i've got real
estate
and i love monopoly i love monopoly so
you just need to understand the game
and once you understand the game but
this doesn't sound like you we're
talking about other people this doesn't
sound like you
you do sound like you're having a
horrible time
the streets aren't for you it's not yet
yeah not right now this is actually
aren't for you
you've also in my opinion you've also
not peaked yet like
during uni between 18 and 21 you've not
peaked like you are still gonna have
a great five six seven eight nine years
you know when you hit that
27-28-29 region come chat to us again
yeah yeah that's what you need to say
and that's the thing as well this is the
thing
also that people don't understand
especially when you're in the streets at
18
yeah because when you're 18 in the
streets you're not buff i don't care
what anyone says you're not buff
you're not bothered you're thinking
about everyone in uni thinks they're the
tits they're not they're not
so you're smashing girls who just want
to smash
and when you're both there because you
don't necessarily want to smash each
other you just both want to smash
and you're at uni it's not it's not
great
yeah but when you when you grow up when
you give yourself yeah like early
twenties
if you manage to if you manage to to
catch it
when you're um if you manage to catch it
while you're still at uni great i think
i caught anthem like
the cusp yeah just on the back end i
didn't but yeah if you if you manage to
to glow up and get buff like trust me
the streets will be different because
you won't just be smashing people
because you happen to be in the streets
and they happen to be in the streets
you'll be smashing people because you're
lusting for this girl
and she's lusting you for you because
you're both bad you're both
banging and that game that's a different
level the sexual energy is different
yeah that's tier two yeah that's just
not lips in a random stranger in a phone
party
and then going home and banging a phone
party that's just like that's
grim that will make you feel [ __ ] about
yourself because you're just like this
girl doesn't even like me
she just wanted to not and i just wanted
to know i didn't even know her name
but tomorrow i probably won't even
remember what she looks like those
that that that entry level of the
streets is
gross and that's where you're at it's
grim that's just everyone trying to play
the field for the sake of it yeah when
you lust for someone and you think
oh she's banging wait to squeeze you
she's banging and then she
she reciprocates and you think that's
impossible impossible
and then you know this is going to be a
fiery affair and then you both are going
to go back into the streets
that's when you're like all the streets
is lit yeah all the street says lit it's
filled with
exotic fruits bro i'm ready that's when
it gets
sick i love stuff like that yeah you've
got [ __ ] to come bro so go back to your
accidentally [ __ ]
[Laughter]
go back to your ex you go back to your
little old ex
get cozy you have no respect for my man
that's hilarious
that's it i'm joking nah but yeah do
what's best for you bro go back to your
ex for the time being
and then when the streets are ready
they'll call you back but
um yeah they will definitely call you
back when they're ready bro they're not
going anywhere
oh that made me laugh but yeah right now
you're uh
you're you yeah you entered you're a uni
six entry-level game man but um like i
said
give yourself five six seven years when
you're glowing you will see a different
side of yourself and they will see a
different side of you yeah bro
and you yeah man just playing the field
team will yeah will hit you nice
all right well let's play one's gonna go
all right king
so this week guys we are doing one's
gotta go with
tv tv um series shows
movies all of that cool man yeah i'm
here for it cool
uh one's got a goal world cup final
nba game seven wimbledon
final oh i'm annoyed because i know
you're going to pick
super bowl you don't know how i'm going
to pick super bowl yeah super can get
scrapped
i couldn't think of another major final
thing
oh i can what menton would be the final
oh i don't know why i didn't think of
that that's annoying
did you put it now true i haven't made
my decision i just thought of it on the
spot
okay mentality finally all right so no
super bowl mentioned so we've got okay
let me
uh come and pop the gap into it
wimbledon final you've got wimbledon
final
nba game seven nba game seven world cup
final
men's hundred meter final oh see now i
actually don't know that's a good one
thank you for that miner um
i live it's a tough one because
i don't really [ __ ] with football but i
definitely don't [ __ ] with tennis but i
watched the wimbledon final yeah
i think everyone does yeah that was like
our uni thing oh it was yeah yeah yeah
and there's you get into it and it's
nice you like nice [ __ ] like that to get
you into the sport
of course um i feel like hmm
i feel bad for saying this because so
many people are going to disagree with
me
but i think it's this is purely because
i'm english okay
that i'm actually going to get rid of
the world cup final okay
because living here you're surrounded by
football 24 7 your entire life yeah
being in english
like football is just everything every
year everything and everywhere it's
everything and everywhere so the world
cup final as much as a big deal it is
but it's only a big deal it's because
it's the pinnacle
of that thing that you're surrounded
with your entire life yeah
whereas the other ones are things that
you'd never get to see
and you're probably not even interested
in but when it happens
yeah you're excited you're engulfed in
and you're happily like
you want to know everything about that
sport in that one moment
because you're like this is the coolest
[ __ ] of all time and i don't get that i
get excited for the world cup final i do
but it's a different kind of excitement
wimbledon final i'm like i want to book
out my afternoon for this
and i've not even watched any other
match yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm saying
men's hundred meter final oh my god bro
the streets are silent everyone is
schtum
the whole stadium is as soon as that gun
goes off the world
goes crazy 10 seconds those 10 seconds
the planet earth has never been louder
people go
crazy for the 900 meter final and then
you got those
special moments when like usain bolton
broke the world record
bro a world record breaking time in the
men's hundred meter final
is the most glorious experience anyone
can like see
if you see that live you're yeah you're
losing your mind
so that's never going fair enough so
unfortunately i'm going to pick the
world cup final okay i know for a fact
all of our fans are going to be like
tim's you [ __ ] idiot but that's
because they're [ __ ] english
yeah americans don't give a [ __ ] about
the world cup final
they don't give a [ __ ] and i'm saying
they're writing i'm not saying i'm right
or wrong saying anyone's wrong i'm just
saying
if you're english and you're growing up
around football it's just like
i'm just used to it mm-hmm i'm just used
to the world cup final
even though comes around every four
years i'm just like cool like to me is
another game of football
okay everything else on there is like a
crazy event
okay okay so yeah i'm gonna get rid of
the the world cup cool
next one ozark oh god money heist
okay the punisher okay and the outsider
these all tv shows uh i'm gonna i
actually haven't seen it
and i've heard it's very good but i'm
actually gonna get rid of the punisher
you've not seen the punisher i thought
you have yeah
is an actor oh he's a guy bro he's a guy
he's a guy he was in a movie
ah what was it called i think i know
which movie you're talking the mountain
yeah the snowy team yeah yeah and you
can talk about this the same the guy
with um hawkeye
yeah yeah yeah um bodies man in that
movie
what the punisher guy yeah yeah bro for
the little clip he's in he's only in it
for like a minute
and he smacks man up in a way that
you've never seen
in the caravan in the caravan i knew
you're going to talk about that bro
so guys you don't know there's a movie
called um
windy river is it windy wind river wind
river i think it's wind river i think
we're going to
keep talking about double roll so
there's human there's a movie called
wind river yeah
and it's got um the actor who plays
hawkeye
what's his name because i'm gonna find
it crystallia always talks about because
he's got a song
it's jeremy jeremy renner renault jeremy
renner and john berthold
cool so jeremiah anderson is the main
character and they're investigating the
disappearance wind river yeah oh uh yeah
wind river there
investigate the disappearance of john
berthold when his misses in it well he's
mainly his missus isn't it
so basically they when they when they
doing all the investigations they
actually find out thing he's in it as
well elizabeth olsen
um mark captain marvel
she's in it as well captain marvel isn't
it elizabeth
um what's up she's not captain america
what's her name uh
scarlet witch scarlet oh yes yeah yeah
yeah sorry yeah you're right
um cool so yeah they have this flashback
scene of what actually happened
for them to go missing and they got
murdered and it's a scene where my
obviously
my man's girl he works on like a oil rig
or whatever isn't it
and his girl's chilling there he goes
out and his boys come home from the pub
and they're drunk and one of them's
moving to his girl
and he comes in like what's going on and
the girl's crying
she's crying and then um
john burton walks in like yo like what
what the [ __ ] like you man just chill
and they were like oh it's all good it's
all games it's all games and then one of
them's like yeah it's all games he's
like yeah it's all games you guys need
to go now
leave it and he's like yeah yeah yeah
it's all games and then he puts paws on
john in it
just a little is it on his chest a
little tap just to let him know he's
about
he's about he's like go have fun with
your misses in it and he's like yeah
yeah yeah
don't touch me in it and then he pushes
him and then it's a beefing
and a boy that my man steps to him john
cracks his jaw he doesn't think twice he
cracks his jaw and drops him immediately
immediately
immediately he's i feel like he might
he may have anger issues oh his zero to
100 is like that
because he does that in the punisher he
does that in obviously wind river and i
feel like he can emulate the same he
does it in wolf of wall street as well
doesn't he
i can't remember he's a hot header for
wall street i remember he's the guy
that um he gets arrested because jonah
hill is [ __ ] with him
you know he's the guy that puts does the
money deliveries
okay he has to do all the money
deliveries because it's his misses that
straps all the money to her titties it
goes to sweet
um switzerland and stuff so yeah yeah
yeah um
he does all deliveries and jonah's like
[ __ ] with him like he's my money take
my money
like he's take my [ __ ] money like you
[ __ ] like and then he gets effects
he gets so vex he gets arrested um but
yeah bro in that window
he clocks that door so cleanly
immediately
he doesn't wait for the next push he
just rocks him drops him and all the man
came coming he's fighting so many he's
fighting so
he holds his own for as long as he can
as long as he can for like the seven
seconds that he holds his own it's it's
war
yeah these men are thinking what what am
i here for it's like
it's like that my mind i you you man are
wrong with me tonight
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
road man yeah yeah
yeah yeah he yeah he's a little job bird
for himself
yeah that was wild okay cool so
what are the options again the punisher
i said the punisher right yeah yeah the
punisher's got a car you need to watch
the punisher bro yeah i don't know if
i've heard his daughter it's probably
still on there you need to watch it only
because it's him
yeah because i don't really like i never
really liked luke cage and i really
liked uh
the chick january was jessica jones
wherever jessica jones yeah jessica
jones
i didn't really like it though i hate
just iron fist i didn't watch you never
did that that's the one with all four of
them in it
i didn't watch that one i heard it was
all [ __ ] yeah but the punisher bro
the punisher is great okay i'll watch it
punish is great i'll watch it so yeah
you definitely and the only reason why i
wanted to watch the punisher was because
obviously i watched daredevil
yeah and he's like in like a couple yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah bro it's two seasons of
pure arms house all right cool that
story's good okay the punisher is one's
gotta go
this one avengers age of ultron
infinity war end game one's going to go
the original avengers the original
avengers what's that avengers assemble
yeah age of ultron yeah infinity war
infinity war end game
so basically all the avenger movies
i can't even remember what happens in
avengers assemble
avengers assemble is when
um is that the one where the hulk does
this thing with loki like that
i think so i think so and then this is
where tony stark goes into space to
close up the thing he takes the
the bomb that starts up the thing and
all these um things are coming out yeah
that's a cool one sceneries coming down
uh
but it's not that many of them in that
one yeah there's like the hulk there's
hawkeye there's scarlett
johansson yeah yeah iron man and i think
there's captain american thor
yeah that's it uh
um [ __ ] sick age of ultron is banging
age of ultron is [ __ ] sick um i've
seen that maybe a few times
the anchor strings on me
just sick um ultron's a good character
really good character and that's when
the infinity war and infinity war
in game aren't going anywhere they're
movies
movies bro i don't know um that's why i
put this in there
i might have to get rid of the first one
to be fair but that was really impactful
for me
it was the staple was the first one when
they first like
in the circle being yeah in the yeah
when they
was like on the bridge or in the middle
of the street and stuff like that and
then they've all just
coincidentally managed to like come
together and they're all just there yeah
and hulk says dreaming hulk's going nuts
the sickest the sickest moment the
sickest moment it is
it's alive it's live so is that one
going
because age of ultron is sick it is sick
i'm thinking maybe age of ultron should
go
yes as live as it is it's just it was
it's great but it didn't give me i
enjoyed every second of it
i don't want to diminish it but it
didn't give me that like
[ __ ] like my in my chest that's all you
said when the whole screaming and
they're all
they've all managed to come together and
it's the first time all the avengers are
just there in one like
shot yeah you're just like my life is
changing right now
there was no moment in age of ultron
when my life was physically changing
in infinity war and endgame oh my god i
could have died a happy person yeah and
both of them
both of them bro an end game where
they these might think they're defeated
and then you just hear
um falcon on your left yeah and you're
like oh i'm gonna be sick
fam that oh you don't have twitter but
there was a video that was going around
when this when that bit came out and
this
the [ __ ] cinema went wild every time
i watch it goosebumps
on
when the whole of wakanda just comes
through
it's different bro the donny the big
donnie from the other clan in uh from
wakanda
as the april yes yes yes he's chanting
nah nah he's uh it was a great movie
but i feel like age of ultron is one of
those ones where
it it brought out so many different
elements of each character
it did it was a staple movie it was an
important movie to have oh
age of ultron because you could never
have gone from avengers 2 yeah i that's
why i said like i didn't want to
diminish it
because i love the [ __ ] movie i love
that movie
i think it's great it's the first time
you see vision as well first time he's
scared of which let's go
with silva yeah first time everyone
tries to pick up thor's hammer yeah
first time
iron man faces the hulk first fam so
much happens in that movie
yeah the hulk buster fight oh yeah the
the hulk buster armor
fam
it's the first time you and obviously in
avengers the first one you see them all
assemble
right in that one shot but in the first
scene of age of ultron
when they're in like scandinavian like
some snow thing and they're all flying
through and you see each other
if i'm sick you're right it's sick that
is sick because that was the first time
they did that and they emulated that
again in infinity war yeah
that is sick [ __ ] you're right you are
right
that first scene is so dope it's
powerful bro it's like
okay i'm ready to watch this movie you
know you sit up from the jump
yeah [ __ ] me bro so much happened to
that movie
maybe it's not age of ultron it's the
first time as well you see the
relationship between scarlet not scarlet
witch scarlett johansson and
the hulk yeah you know yeah hey there
big boy and blah blah touching the hands
hulk goes missing oh
bro yeah bro it's an important movie it
is a great movie jesus oh
i'm like spoken about ultron ultron's an
amazing villain
he was the first premium villain in the
avengers series
premium premium villain yeah
[ __ ] movie bro [ __ ] ultron dominated
that movie yeah he was sick
but anyway the way they implemented
because that was i
was that the first marvel movie that
was disney oh i don't know it might have
been i might be completely wrong
because i remember them using the
pinocchio song
um for ultron i remember when the
trailer came out and they were using
their ain't
got no strings i don't know and that was
how they that was the trailer it was
okay that want to this day one of the
sickest trailers i've ever seen i need
to probably watch twitter again and i
remember thinking ra
and then my brother was like oh it's
sick how because now disney owns
marvel they can just use that song
because they own that song and that was
one of the first times i was like [ __ ]
it that's
sick these men are using whatever
they've got in their wheelhouse
to make the best movie possible and i
was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're relating ultron to
pinocchio bro
these men have no limits i need to see
that trailer again because i don't know
bro yeah and then because the song's
just playing it's just the music
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then just as you
see ultron was red eyes at the end and
he's like i ain't got no strings on me
and he's just there and you're like [ __ ]
he's ready to scrap
he's ready to scrap everyone yeah okay
age of ultron's a [ __ ] sick movie
obviously first time you see vision go
off yeah
you know what it might have to be the
first avengers then okay because you're
right that
when i said i couldn't there wasn't any
like life-changing bits in there
the hulk buster armor different bro bro
different the way he's just punching and
then the the amount of jets
on the arm just go and then he
gets him against the thing he's got that
like hammers
and then hulk catches it bro when when
um iron man calls for like the cage
thing from space
and it's it circles the hog man just
goes underground and it comes up bro
every time the hulk knocks a bit of
armor off and there's another bit that
just
attaches to him it's so sick
that moment was actually life-changing
it's insane i was like this is crazy
i remember thinking what am i watching
this is crazy
yeah sick okay first of all first of all
all right guys please
tell me at home which one you picked
because i know this one is hard it's
it's not
it's not an easy choice that's obviously
the reason why i picked it yeah but
anyway
so avengers girls right next one friday
okay rush hour okay coming to america
okay bad boys so are we doing
not the series the individual individual
first movies okay
friday rush hour coming to america and
bad boys because if i
include the series coming to america too
i've not seen and i know that's trash
and that will diminish yeah you're right
you know um i think this one's quite
easy for me actually okay
i'm gonna get rid of friday okay why
people i don't know i just feel like
friday for me
is one of those movies that i
it's not it's not friday's fault it's
everyone else's fault that i don't
[ __ ] with friday that much not not
friday as far okay it's because
obviously i saw it when i was a kid like
everyone else saw it yeah yeah
and to me it was just like cool and then
you grub up and then everyone makes out
like it's the greatest movie ever made
and yeah and then i watched it again not
long ago um
during lockdown um at like this open
cinema thing
okay and i watched it again and i was
just like it's just a movie like it's
not even
that funny um whereas rush hour
is fun [ __ ] i know russia i think i
know rush hour lyric for lyric
bro rush hour is funny rush hour two is
even better than number one which is
crazy
coming to america is funny funny i've
watched coming to america like 10 times
because amazing and even there's still
bits now i'm like that's funny bro
like um sexual chocolate bro
that was good that boy is good
i was like settle chocolate and he just
drops the mic
it's so funny bro that is so funny
but there isn't a bit there's not a
single bit in friday where i barely
laugh
yeah yeah yeah okay i can just watch it
and be like all right cool
um rush hour coming to america what was
the other one bad boys bad boy bad boys
is iconic
yeah of course have you seen bad boys
for life no i haven't
seen it but yeah the first bad boy is d
is actually like decent
i just i've i've seen that load i've
seen one or two loads of times yeah
loads of times so yeah batboy stays
uh and actually say yeah friday friday
can get kicked man cool
say no more is that one of them no
there's one more oh one more game
uh recess oh my god ed and eddie
yeah hey arnold yeah johnny bravo
that's a tough one that's a tough one
um recess i can say now recess ain't
going
anywhere this is top three i love recess
amazing um i've probably watched every
episode and the movie twice
yeah but recess is [ __ ] just jokes
back in the day spinster
spinster nah mrs spinster
and it's crazy when you realize the the
references when you go up because like
someone who is an old spinster is like
an old nasty person yeah
yeah yeah but when you're a kid i didn't
know what spinster meant i just thought
it was mrs spinster
and he realized that oh she's called mrs
spitzer because she's an old [ __ ] yeah
yeah she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] she's wearing
glasses yeah yeah so jarring and what
was the man
that his little pet a little pet what's
his name randolph was it random i don't
know
he was like it was ran something he was
a prick and we googled it
um he was such a tattletale he was such
a little snitch in it
you wanted to knock it out it was a
little due from
um let me google it as well actually but
yeah like
i [ __ ] hated it man it was ran
something
snitch in recess
these men know what i'm talking about
randall randall right yeah yeah yeah
randall
randall yeah bro
randall j weems [ __ ] that guy
he was such an awesome [ __ ] that guy it
was such an awesome um
and then tj's cool i v i was obsessed
with vince
i wanted to be there i could imagine i
could imagine he wanted to be
i wanted to be vince i couldn't imagine
i remember the episode where he um
got a job in the kitchen and he was
making the school dinners and he was he
was like the most banging chef
and everyone was gassed and i remember
thinking man there's nothing this kid
can't do
there's nothing this kid can't do a gal
he can bowl he can cook
he can hoop he can cook he he gets all
the girl he's just flying
and then like uh obviously mikey started
with his singing and stuff like that
gus was just guarding that was just guys
he can't hate gun guns yeah yeah he's
gonna hate
the guy that he's just part of the gang
yeah yeah gus was gus
and um spinelli was going spinelli was
gang
ander gretchen jacob's just cool man she
was just the geeky cool one cool geeky
cool one and then when she learned about
the yo-yos but she got her own
like like with the yo-yo one that she
was doing
she yo yeah yeah
now i'm ready um so we've got sorry
recess
i did an eddie bro jawbreaker top tier
cop jawbreakers
top tier card plank top tier cartoon bro
eddie nilly was the one bro
ah and then hey arnold johnny bravo
i think johnny bravo's gonna have to go
but i did love johnny bravo
but never johnny bravo was just if it's
on i'm watching it yeah but it was never
like you can seek out for it bro i'll
never look for johnny brother
it was one of them was if you're just
scrolling through the channels and you
see johnny bravo there you go all right
and put it on and i enjoyed it i loved
it but like bro i would
i'd be thinking it's three o'clock i'm
gonna miss eden eddie yeah yeah yeah
like i'm vex
like i'm gonna miss it um and that's
pretty much like all of them
yeah johnny bravo can go editing hey
arnold
movie football head hey arnold was like
a weird
dark had like a really dark undertone as
well yeah and it was cool i liked having
arnold
with his granddad what was wrong with
his grandma's head back
he had like a little titty on his head
back here his head was mad pointy bro
headshot was janky
hey arnold characters um and uh
they're listening to me [ __ ] hell i
just typed in hey did you really yeah
they actually are like
characters yeah they are listening bro
it's crazy oh grand yeah yeah
his head shape was murked look at it
that's banana from his chin yeah to his
head
yeah yeah yeah yeah um bro did you ever
think as well
am i right and wrong in thinking that
courage the cowardly dog is the scariest
cartoon of all time
i've got that in one of my things yeah
yeah yeah courageous
it's different bro it's terrifying it's
not for
kids it's 100 not for kids but how we
got onto cartoon network is beyond me
how someone signed off and like thought
yeah boom we can put this on a seven
terrifying bro i hate it i loved it but
i
hated it for it it was different i never
knew what was gonna happen next
it was horrible um but yeah
cool um so johnny bravo jonah bravo's
getting axed
cool so your axe once our world cup
final punisher
avengers friday and johnny bravo guys at
home
let me know which one you picked that
was a good one i enjoyed that a lot glad
you did them
cool so we've got another [ __ ] yeah
this one's easy it's crazy
gang hit me i love them all right am i
the [ __ ] my boyfriend of three years
has been messaging multiple girls on
every social media
and even received a few nudes what the
[ __ ]
so i slept with one of his teammates on
the school varsity the [ __ ]
this that's a those two lines are so
toxic
what an introduction the bang was
horrendous
and he wasn't working with much but now
i feel like i have the upper hand
because none of his messages hinted that
he'd slept with any of those girls
am i an [ __ ] if i stay with him
because i'm not mad anymore
what is going on bro what is going on
who had am i an [ __ ] for staying with
him because i'm not mad anymore
yes yes you are an [ __ ] bro
so she caught donnie messaging next
things
then for bear grabs one of his teammates
bangs him discards him
and then says i'm actually not even mad
anymore i've got my own back
i've got revenge what relationship is
they've been given for three years
what's been going on what kind of
relationship
is this first of all how are you
clocking
he's receiving nudes speaking to
multiple things and you've not addressed
this
because you've seen this and thought
bet i need to one-up him bro
the fact that she managed to see all of
this
and then just keep it inside her chest
and then decide like
all right i'm gonna do my thing now like
to keep that down and act normal
bro this reminds me there was a time one
of our friends
one of our friends got caught out one
time doing some
shady things but then he and his mrs
had a holiday plant okay so she found
out the dirt hmm
but didn't want to ruin the holiday i
think i remember coming so held it in
her chest for like two weeks
and then brought out when she got back i
was like that's the craziest thing i've
ever heard
that's mental how that is mental just
holiday you know playing love birds
that is mental no no no no no
no no no no no she had the audacity to
grab a teammate of his
his knowing full the bread the boy who
knows full well that these men are
together
yeah bro and he thought [ __ ] it let's go
let's go
i've got no loyalties i've got no
loyalties to him and i've got nothing to
lose
that that oh these circles that some of
you man roll in
bro are different the bro i'm telling
you man
gen z were born into toxicity 100 100
100
100 because gen z were born into human
toxic environment
no no repercussions you don't care about
the reaper they don't understand what a
repercussion is
they're not it means nothing to them
what do you mean you've been together
for three years and this is how we're
acting
there's a there's a little bonus bit at
the end okay okay by the way i love your
pod
my boyfriend got us a subscription to
your patreon a couple times
my this my man that she's telling us
she's telling us that she cheated on
she's then using him
as a caveat to say oh we love your [ __ ]
both of us as a team as a unison
we love what you're doing we love you
guys oh you've added money into your
pocket
she knows she's staying with him nah bro
she's certain of it no bro
no bro she doesn't care about how he's
acting she
i'm so sorry you don't love him you
don't she obviously she knows she
doesn't love her i think she's staying
with him
do you i don't know what i don't know
what the reasoning is i don't know what
the reasoning is
because that is an opener shot case and
it's the one of the maddest ones you've
read to me
it's one of the mad those first two
lines bro
i wasn't expecting that three years
she's been clocking that he's been
getting nudes and talking to next women
women so therefore i slept with his
teammate
and now i'm not even mad anymore now i
feel better i feel better i'm not angry
and the beat was trash so that makes me
want my man back even more
oh my god so in her head the beef is
squashed
they've never even discussed any of this
they're just both going to be living
their secret lives
oh my god so what's this like every time
she catches my man out
she's just gonna go do herself a thing
and then just come back to normal and
everything's fine makes no
sense that doesn't make any sense she's
a psychopath oh oh 100 she's a
psychopath
you're going to kill someone one day
because for you to be able to hide such
feelings and stay in a relationship
and do the thing you're doing on the
side because your boyfriend's doing a
thing on the side if
he's even doing anything he's just
getting nudes he's not even slept with
two hours she's not slept with anyone
else and you can just act
normal bro she's the type of girl
that's definitely started a rumor in
school
just to see what would happen about a
[ __ ] that she didn't like yeah
she's 100 yeah yeah yeah decided one day
i actually hate jessica yeah and then
just told everyone that jessica just
loves anal
when they were like seven years old yeah
so it was like back then
it's like that's what they were like
year two she just told everyone jessica
loves aino
just to see what would happen just to
see jessica's world crumble
and she was the one to that pattern on
the back
it's always the ones closer to you guys
bro i said it to you man a couple
episodes ago women
they're not for women then women aren't
for women sometimes they're just not for
women i know this is hypothetical yeah
she definitely did it
she definitely did it she definitely did
it
that's hilarious yeah bro um he's you're
an [ __ ] you are clear
you and your man are both so i don't
know what's going on you might need to
go your separate ways
talk and go your separate ways yeah
because this is this is disgraceful
behavior
but yeah guys case
sorry um guys this is us signing off
we love you we'll see you next week uh
we hope you're doing well jump on the
patreon as per
up the likes jump in the comments um
and guys diomas or you am i the [ __ ]
because
these are too juicy they are man all
right